- She's a new mama and Olympic
gold medalist in soccer
who has been on the forefront
of fighting for equitable pay
for men and women in sports.
And she's also co-launching
a new media company called
TOGETHXR just for younger women.
Let's everybody say hi to Alex Morgan.
(audience cheers)
Hi!
- Hey Kelly.
- Well, I just saw this video of you
that you posted of your baby girl.
We're gonna show it.
She's super cute!
- Aw, thank you.
She had so much fun, she's a water baby.
- I love that.
I loved the water, I think
it feels rejuvenating.
So any sign she's gonna be into soccer?
- Oh, she better! No pressure.
But we'll see.
I keep putting a soccer
ball in front of her
and she wants nothing to do with it.
So hopefully one day.
- Well, how is your prep for
the Tokyo Olympics going?
- Oh, it's good.
I mean, we are in like full prep mode.
And, you know, on the field
every single day getting ready.
And obviously, you know,
looking forward to it so much.
And for me, I kind of get a second chance
because it would have been really close
after having my daughter last year.
So, now pushing it to this year,
I'm really excited for
that second opportunity.
- Yeah. Silver lining.
So you have a great new project
that I want to talk about.
It's called TOGETHXR.
Can you tell everybody a little about it?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So TOGETHXR is a media
company that myself,
Chloe Kim, Simone Manuel,
and Sue Bird co-founded.
And it is a media company
that really wants to put out
stories and inspire young women
with these amazing stories
from female athletes.
We've also included culture and fashion
into that sport lifestyle.
So I feel like it's just
all about like empowering
and encouraging and
motivating girls and women
to do whatever they want to do.
You know, to go after
their dreams and goals.
- Absolutely.
How has your daughter
deepened your passion
for gender equality in sports?
Because I know fighting
for myself is one thing,
but fighting for your loved one
is a completely different ball game.
So I feel like it got like more so for me.
Do you feel the same?
- Yeah. I feel like I've
been like full into,
you know, fighting against
U.S. Soccer, our employer,
for gender equality and for equal pay
now for the last, ooh
man, five or six years.
So it's been a long time now,
but I feel like it's just
continuing to pick up
now that I have my daughter
and now that I'm surrounded by
so many other inspiring women.
And now that I'm one of
the veterans on the team,
not only do I have my daughter,
but I have like this next
generation of players
that are coming in
and like just looking up to
everything that we do and say
and like what we're fighting for.
So it's even more important now.
And TOGETHXR also gives me
that platform to be able to
really change people's like
mindset in knowing that.
And we need guys to support
us as well, you know?
- I don't think the change will happen
unless men do support it as well.
I agree with that statement.
I also, like, I don't
watch a ton of sports ball,
which is why I call it sports ball.
But my point is, when I do watch it,
'cause I have a lot of girlfriends
and family that love sports.
When I do watch it, I find that they,
I'm like, we just saw this.
Like they just showed this
play like 15 minutes ago
or we just saw this.
And they keep repeating things.
And I'm like,
I guess for people that
are just now tuning in.
But I'm like, okay.
So my point just from a complete outsider
is you're not gonna take
away a coverage of the men.
We already saw it.
You just keep playing
it over and over again.
There's room to add the women in there.
And then still everybody
still gets the same.
You're still seeing.
It just seems like they
cover those same things
over and over which is why
I don't like watching it.
- That's the thing it's like,
it's not as zero-sum game.
And that's why we created TOGETHXR.
Because, we were like, okay,
well, if they're not
gonna have space for us
on the biggest networks,
then we're gonna create
our own like platform
to share these stories,
to show that these women's
stories should be accessible.
You know, growing up,
I didn't really have professional
athletes on my walls.
I had singers and actresses
because I didn't know any athletes
because they weren't on TV.
All I saw were men on TV.
- Yeah. No, I think
representation is super important.
Well, thank you so much, Alex.
Good luck on everything.
- Yeah, thank you so much.
Thanks for having me.
(audience cheers)
- Yeah. Good luck on mostly being a mama.
It's a really cool thing.
It's a hard thing but it's the
coolest thing you'll ever do.
- Yeah. It's tough.
I'm a mom first and athlete
second, but I'm happy with that.
- Absolutely, absolutely
Well, don't forget to tune
into NBC starting July 23rd
for all your Olympics coverage.